hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game we'll be showing from
round 11 of the
2021 tata still chess masters it's
ariantari versus andre esipenko as we
mentioned in the previous video we said
that esipengo has
excellent chances of winning the
tournament because he already went
through all of the big names in the
tournament and
he he's the only one who defeated magnus
carlsen so let's see how he does with
the black pieces against another
norwegian
arianthari uh without further ado let's
check it out so
tari with the white pieces opens with e4
sorry about that uh we have e5 by spenco
uh knight to f3 knight to c6 and bishop
to b5
uh targo is 40 rule lopez with a6
morpheus defense and now bishop to a4
and now uh esipenko goes for d6 this is
the so-called modern steins defense you
want to play
g7 a g6 developer bishop to g7 and so on
we have castles here knight to f6 and
now rook to e1
defending the e4 pawn we have bishop to
d7 and now
c3 preparing to strike in the center
also
creating an escape route for this bishop
here so g6 as planned and the white
immediately goes for d4
uh we bishop to g7 and now knight b to
d2 going after some standard knight f1
to g3 or e3 ideas
uh castles by black and now bishop to c2
and here there are some 10 games in the
database that reach this exact same
position most
uh notable one being uh krishnan
sasikram versus hikaru nakamura
it was from uh 2019 world blitz
championship nakamura defeated him
by playing rook to e8 but here we have
knight to h5
and it is already as of move 10 that we
have a completely new game so is
panko preparing to bring the knight over
to f4 maybe f5 will be an idea in the
future
and so on so uh somewhat of an
aggressive approach
uh and here we have d captures an e5 you
don't have to capture this
it's a matter of preference you could go
d5 knight to f1 then shoot the knight to
g3
but tari decides to capture once first
we have captures captures and
now knight to f1 we have knight to f4
uh that knight is now an excellent piece
here uh and if white doesn't want to
give up the
dark square bishop and of course white
doesn't want to do that you want to keep
your bishop pair we have
knight to e3 here so this knight is now
coming to d5
and d5 will be an excellent outpost for
white's knight
king to h8 getting the king away from
this diagonal at some point in the
future we want to play f5 so you don't
want to
constantly be looking over your shoulder
and now knight to d5 and here
uh black cannot capture this knight if
black captures this then you remove the
defender of the e5 pawn you pick up the
e5 pawn and it's uh
pretty much pretty much a game over for
black so instead after this knight to d5
we have knight back to e6
and now tari just starts pushing on the
king side with
h4 and this is already
somewhat of a critical moment in the in
the game
because here uh espanko needs to figure
out how to deal with this of course uh
h5 is coming that's pretty clear and
here is panko decided to stop it with
h5 but i will just show a very very
interesting line
that follows what is benko was was
planning to do all along and that's
f5 f5 seems like a
a completely different approach but it
is a very interesting one
because it offers a lot of counter play
for black
for example if white continues pushing
let's say h5
you can even close up the position with
f4 and if h captures on g6 you just go
knight to g5 and this is a this is a
not a good position for white bishop to
g4 is coming you're going to put a lot
of pressure on this knight on f3
if captures and captures then again you
are threatening f3
again something you don't want to face
not right away the bishop of course is
uh
still on c1 but it is a very unpleasant
position for
uh for white and even if white goes for
this trick knight captures on f4
to pick up the bishop on d7 you're just
gonna pick it up e
captures on f4 queen captures on d7 uh
and now
knights the e5 again uh not not
the greatest position for why the queen
is under attack knight to f3 check is
coming
you have to block it with queen to h3
and now queen to g6 now definitely
preparing to push f3
it's a very very difficult position for
white to play
so ideas like this were in the position
uh but
instead of going for f5 is bank who goes
for h5 and now this means he's going to
opt for
for a defensive setup with f6 to keep
that
knight in bay and adds additional
support to the e5 pawn and he will be on
the defensive
so bishop to e3 and now f6
uh we have b4 dari now continues pushing
on the queen side and
knight to e7 now trying to trade off
this uh this
strong knight on d5 queen to e2 and now
uh instead of trading over the knight
knight the c8 now preparing to shift the
knight to d6
and from there you will also have a lot
a lot of presence in the center
so here c4 uh just cementing that knight
on b5 also grabbing more space on the
queen side
queen to e8 now maybe with ideas of
bishop to a4 to trade off the the light
square bishop here
uh but tary doesn't mind he doesn't
block it with a4 he just continues with
c5
clears the c4 square for his queen also
grabs more space here on the queen side
and now we have
a5 here yesipenko wants to open up the a
file for his rook
we have a3 and now knight to a7 the
knight is now coming to b5
and then maybe in the future even to d4
so
bishop to b3 and now knight to b5
we have bishop to c4 now with a double
attack on the knight here
captures on b for captures and esi pinko
trays here with rook captures
rook captures and now again a very
tricky position
it's hard for black to find the move
like we said the knight is already
attacked twice rook to a5 will add a
third attacker to the knight
and you're not gonna you're not gonna
have all that many squares
for example if black plays something
like bishop c6 you're gonna go after the
knight
and the knight now has to move the
problem is after you move this knight
uh white will just capture it bishop
captures and you cannot capture with the
knight if you capture with the knight
the white just trades and then picks up
the c7 pawn
and if you don't if you want to keep an
eye on the c7 point then you have to
capture with this pawn and then the rook
just goes back rook a1 to d1 and then
you're gonna pick up the d4 pawn
uh or black will have to further weaken
his position so
it's uh it's uh not not a lot of moves
for black in this position so
uh uh taking the heat of the queen side
is panko decides to strike on the king
side and here he plays
f5 uh but as you'll see this is uh
not not the the greatest
route for for black to take so here e
captures an f5 and now
not rook captures an f5 but rather the
brave g
captures on f5 which is incredibly uh
hard to imagine that black would go for
this as the h5 pawn is now
uh how will you ever defend this this h5
pawn uh yes the queen is defending it
for now but that can
change in a second here knight to g5
and knight to g5 is now a great move for
white because uh
again what do you play here for black
i'm just going to show you what happens
if black plays
some sort of a careless move let's say
black plays f4
uh feel free to pause the video and try
to win this hypothetical position
for white while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh
spotting of course the beautiful rook
the a8
of course that's also for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show uh and
now
white black simply resigns the queen is
under attack you cannot capture the rook
if you capture the rook
it's just a very simple queen captures
on h5 check and that's it king g8
and now queen h7 or knight to e7 will be
checkmate
so what happens if you don't capture the
rook let's say you go something like
queen to g6
that's also not gonna do because of
knights the e7 and now the queen cannot
remain on this diagonal
uh so the queen has to move somewhere
you have to guard the h5 pawn
queen to h6 and now comes knight to f7
with check the rule cannot capture of
course the rook is now pinned
so you have to go king h7 and now just
bishop the c to check
and the queen has to block queen g6 and
now bishop captures his checkmate
so this is uh not the way to go for
black but it's uh
extremely hard to defend against this
how how do you defend against rook to a8
it's not
uh not some sort of a position that can
just be played you you cannot play
something like bishop the c8 the white
will still play this and then capture
the bishop the queen will still have to
leave the defense of the h5 pawn so here
uh ispinko tried knight to g5
eliminating the knight
h captures and g5 and now f4
now there's a an attacker less so he
hopes to survive with queen to g6 but
still
uh tari just goes for rook to a8 of
course again you cannot capture if you
capture now yes there is no knight but
still queen captures on h5
uh and now there's nothing to be done if
king to g8 just
queen to e7 checkmate and that's just it
you don't need the other knight
so instead after rook to a8 we have
queen to g6
as planned and now comes rook captures
and f8 with
check bishop captures and now uh bishop
to d2
uh now uh you you don't you don't want
black to capture this and you are still
threatening to capture the knight on b5
and there's no good move here once the
knight
moves away from b5 and frees up the c3
square the dark square bishop is coming
here
and not a lot can be done about this or
what was played in the game
knight the a3 but now the much sneakier
bishop to d3
attacking the queen and what do you do
here uh you have queen captures on g5
now with some ideas of pushing maybe f3
trying to go for some sort of a queen
trade now just bishop to e4
and there is no defense against uh
all of the threats that white has so it
was in this position on move 33 that
andre is resigned to the game
and with it uh excellent chances of
actually winning this tournament because
there is nothing more to be done here
checkmate is being threatened
once you defend against this now you
will bishop the c3 and that's it
there's no way to defend against bishop
captures this whatever you play any move
runs into bishop captures here and now
it's just
game over next movie you're going to
play queen to h7 checkmate
uh doesn't matter what you do uh because
of course the the queen will not be able
to capture and if you capture
the light square bishop here which is
also possible then
bishop captures comes with check and
only then will you recapture here and
then you're just up a queen
so yeah after queen to e4 uh espanko
resigned and an
excellent victory for aryan tari and now
we are going to check out the standings
after 11 rounds there are two more
rounds to go so anything can still
happen
these are the standings so let's check
it out uh anish geary is still leading
the tournament with seven out of ten
with two more rounds to go uh followed
by with six and a half andre sipenko you
can see that
if panko uh drew or won this game he he
could have been
uh in first place fabiano corwana and
alireza firuja who drew their
insane game uh also both on six and a
half out of ten so trailing by
by a half a point and uh interestingly
uh
uh just wanted to mention when uh fabi
missed that
knight captur sanji to move uh someone
mentioned in the comments that uh
in the interview after the game fabi
actually said that he was considering
uh uh to play this move for some 40
minutes before he decided to play a c6
so i
it it definitely was not a missed idea
uh
with six uh jordan one forest with five
and a half magnus carlson with five
points pentaho recreation and niels
grandelius
with four youngsters of duda maxim
bashar al-agrav and aryan tari
uh rashik and david anton gihara with
three and a half out of ten and
alexander donchenko
with three out of ten so there we have
it those are the standings two more
rounds to go we'll see what happens
uh our leader anish giri faces alireza
ferrugia today so it's going to be
it's going to be an epic battle i
imagine uh but you know
we'll see what happens uh so yeah i hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank
michael alexandre de la here uh anil
john nicely
thomas gallagher and robert steenberg
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and
i will see you soon uh continuing the
coverage of the tata steel
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day